وزاره البيئه المصريه ترد في تفاعلكم على
ادعاءات حول هجوم القرش وتفاصيل صادمه
جديده في قصه نجاه الاطفال الكولومبيين من
الادغال وبلسانهم هم ومقطع فيديو لخطف
فتاه في وضح النهار يشغل الليبيين اهلا
بكم
قصه يعني خلينا نقول مسار اهتمام العالم
كانت الايام الماضيه وهي الحادثه المؤسفه
اللي صارت معاه الشاب الروسي فلاديمير فو
بوف اللي عمره كان 23 سنه وفقد حياته بسبب
هجوم من سمكه قرش في الغردقه بمصر الجديد
اليوم انه تقرير وزاره البيئه عن الحادثه
طلع وتضمن انه الهجوم صار على مسافه 50
متر من خط الساحل بمنطقه مياه ضحله ما
بيتعدى عنقها ثلاثه امتار وهي منطقه يعني
معتد دائما فيها السباحه وفيها عدد من
الكائنات البحريه مثل الشعب المرجانيه
والطحالب وغيرها وانه سمكه القرش اللي
هاجمت الشاب الروسي فضلت اكثر من ثلاث
ساعات متواصله في المكان وانه خروجه لسطح
الماء سلوك مو طبيعي وانه عمليه الهجوم
تمت بغرض التغذيه المباشره على الضحيه
واكد تقرير وزاره البيئه انه المنطقه اللي
صار فيها الحادث اي اعمال بتتسبب باثاره
القرش والتعرض لهجماته ومن الاخبار
الجديده اليوم النوفلاديمير ما كان سائح
مثل ما كان الكل مفكر ونقل الاعلام في
البدايه لا الشاب كان جاي هو وعائلته
علشان يستقروا في مصر حسب مصرح والده اللي
قال انهم مجهز كل الاوراق اللازمه علشان
يستقر في مصر ودخل في شراكه مع احد ابناء
الغردقه للاستثمار والاستيراد والتصدير
بين مصر وروسيا
وخلال تقديم واجب العزاء من السكرتير
العام لمحافظه البحر الاحمر للوالد قال
انه اللي صار مع ابنه قضاء وقدره وبيرفض
المتاجره بالحادث او انه هذه مو المره
الاولى اللي بيجي فيها الغردقه وخلال
الساعات الماضيه انتشر على المنصات فيديو
لسائح روسي مع راقصه في مطعم وقال
المتداولين انه اخر فيديو للش الراحل لكن
بعد البحث والتدقيق اتضح انه هذا خبر مزيف
والفيديو مول الضحيه الفيديو طلع من قصه
قديمه وعمره اكثر من تسع سنوات طيب تطور
جديد اخر عن القصه او في القصه هذه وحقيقه
لافت هو اخبار نقلتها صحيفه المصري اليوم
نقلا عن مصادر بيئيه قالت انه وزاره
البيئه استوردت اكثر من سنه ونصف اجهزه
رصد وتتبع اسماك القرش لمراقبه سلوكها
والتعرف على اسباب مهاجمتها للانسان لكن
المصادر بتقول انه هذه الاجهزه للان ما تم
استخدامها ابدا مع انها حصلت على الموافقه
الامنيه والتقليص الجمركي واستوفت كل
الاوراق من عام ونصف والسؤال طبعا ايش مدى
صحه الاخبار ولو حقيقه ليه ما استخدمت هذه
الاجهزه طيب احنا معنا من الغردقه عبر
الهاتف الدكتور محمد سالم رئيس قطاع حمايه
الطبيعه في وزاره البيئه المصريه اهلا فيك
معانا دكتور محمد خلينا نبتدي من النقطه
الاخيره اللي هي نقلتها صحيفه المصري
اليوم نقلا عن مراصد هل فعلا كان في اجهزه
لتتبع اسماك القرش موجوده عندكم ولكن لم
يتم استخدامها
لا طبعا هي الاجهزه طبعا دي احنا
استوردناها مخصوص عشان نستعملها بس
استعمالها مرتبط بوقت معين عشان نقدر نعظم
الاستفاده من النتائج اللي احنا
هنتحصل عليها من خلال استخدام هذه الاجازه
لان القبر مرتبط بسلوكيات الانواع من
اسماك المستهدفه بهذه الدراسه عشان نقدر
نفهم سلوكها الحركي خلال عام كامل
فبالتالي تركيبها مرتبط بوقت معين عشان
حتى كمان عشان نقدر نتحصل على العينات من
الاسماك اللي احنا هنركب عليها الاجهزه
نفسها
الامر مرتبط بمواسم تزاوج واماكن ظهور هذه
الاسماك في اماكن معينه في اوقات معينه في
السنه اوكي طيب يعني فالموضوع ما له علاقه
انه لو كنتم استخدمتو هذه الاجهزه ما كان
صار اللي صار لا لا الاجهزه ديت احنا
جبناها ضمن برنامج شامل وزاره البيئه
بتتبناها من اكثر يمكن من 12 سنه لان احنا
بدايه اهتمام وزاره البيئه بظاهره هجوم
اسماك القرش على البشر بدات يمكن من 12
سنه مش وليده هذا الحادث او قبل كده يعني
احنا اشتغلنا على الموضوع دوت وكل ما
بنشتغل طبعا كل ما بتظهر اسئله محتاجه
اجوبه فبالتالي كان فكره الاستعانه بهذه
الاجهزه الحديثه على اساس نقدر من خلالها
نقدر نجاوب على بعض الاجهزه اللي ما زال
الاسئله
غامضه بالنسبه الان في الحاله اللي صارت
صار في كثير تضارب عن سبب انه القرش اكل
السائح في ناس كانت بيقولوا انه القرش كان
بيبحث عن اكل في ناس بيقولوا انه كان او
كانت حامل لانها انثى فكانت قريبه من الشط
في ناس بيقولوا انه لا كانت ولدت وبتحاول
تحمي مواليدك كانت في حاله هستيريه هل
فهمتوا ايش السبب
هو طبعا كل اللي انت حطيتك بتقوليها ديت
مرتبطه بمجهودات دول تانيه اشتغلت كتير
على نفس الطائره في الدول بتاعتها
التفسيرات دي كلها مش تفسيرات افتراضيه دي
نتائج ابحاث ودراسات تمت في دول بتتشابه
البيئه بتاعتها بشكل كبير مع البيئه
المصريه
والنوع ده من القروش بالذات او اللي
بيسموه تايجر شارك هو بعض الدراسات تمت في
دول اخرى وانتهت من خلال استخدام اجهزه
التتبع بس لما انتم مسكتوا لتايجر شارك
ايش لقيته وهذا تحديدا احنا لقيناه طبعا
هو في ايميل فعلا وده كان بيتطابق مع
الافتراض اللي احنا مفترضينه بناء على
المشاهدات بتاعتنا خلال السنين اللي فاتت
وكانت ماتشور يعني ناضجه جنسيا يعني وكانت
في مرحله متوسطه من مراحل تطور الاجنه
جواها
اتعدادا لوضع الاجنه وده نسبيا بيتطابق مع
النتائج العالميه اللي اهتمت
بدراسه هذه الظاهره
محمد بيانكم كان بيقول انه القرش بيعاني
او القرش
بنسوق التغذيه او قله التغذيه او انه بغرض
التغذيه بغرض التغذيه تبحث عن الاكل كانت
يعني هو ده عامل تاني هي لما بتهاجر من
مكان معيشتها في المياه المفتوحه الساحليه
بتستهدف من الموضوع دوت كذا حاجه الحاجه
الاولانيه انها تضع الصغار بتاعتها في
اماكن امنه لان وضع الاجنه في المياه
المفتوحه بيعرضها للافتراض بشكل سهل جدا
من خلال الانواع الاخرى من القروش وفي نفس
الوقت ما بتقدرش تلاقي احتياجاتها من
الغذاء احنا بنتكلم دلوقتي على سمكه صغيره
الحجم محتاجه انها تتوفر لها مصادر غذاء
فتناسب مع احتياجاتها الغذائيه فدي اللي
انتهى اليه العالم في قصه تفسير هجره هذا
النوع من الاسماك اثناء مواسم وهي بتهاجر
لو تسمحي لي بتحتاج تتغذى بشكل كبير
لتوفير طاقه لدعم نمو الاجنه قبل عمليه
الولاده عشان القروش او الصغار الاجنه لما
تنزل تبقى هيلتي لما بيقابلها صعوبات في
هذا الامر وما تلاقيش وفره الغذاء اثناء
عمليه الهجره ديت طبعا
احتمالات بحثها على مصادر اكل ثانيه بتزيد
فقد يكون دوت بيؤدي الى زياده معدلات هجوم
هذا النوع من القروش
على البشر خلال هذه الفتره ودي بردك نتائج
توصل اليها العالم احنا من خلال استخدام
الاجهزه اللي احنا بنجيبها عايزين نتحقق
من نفس السيناريو اللي بيحصل في الدول
الاخرى بيتطابق بس دكتور محمد عشان بدي
استغل الوقت معك في ناس طلعوا وهاجموا
انكم انتم مسكتوا السمكه وقتل او القرش
وقتلته القرش وما الى ذلك كيف بتردوا على
هذه الاصوات
اللي حضرتك
افتراضيه اعتقد هو بيغيب عنهم حقايق علميه
كتير يعني هو اسماك القرش يمكن مصر من
تعتبر الدوله الوحيده في العالم اللي
بتحمي اسماك القرش بشكل كامل طبقا لحكم
القانون لاهميه هذا الكائن للاتزان البيئي
والصناعه السياحه العالم كله ودي برضك
يعني اللي بيتداولوا هذا الكلام غايب عنهم
حقيقه ان العالم يصطاد 100 مليون سمكه قرش
سنويا ومعظم دول العالم المتقدم من اكبر
الدول اللي بتستهدف هذه الانواع وخصوصا
التايجر شارك
في بروتوكولات عالميه بتنظم التعامل مع
الحوادث هجوم اسماك القرش على البشر ومعظم
الدول هذه البروتوكولات بتنادي بمحاوله
صيد السمكه المتسببه في الحادث للحد من
تكرارها على الهجوم على انسان تاني وذلك
حفاظا على ارواح البشر لان بتعتبر دي من
ضمن اولويات معظم دول العالم وكذلك الوضع
في مصر سلوك السمكه اللي تم رصده بعد
الحادث اكد ان السمكه بتحاول تبحث عن
فريسه اخرى وده ظاهره غير طبيعيه معظم
حوادث اسماك القرش اللي بتحصل بتبقى عضه
واحده وبيترك الفريسه ويمشي على اساس ان
هو بيتيقن من العضه دي ان هذا الكائن ليس
من مصادر اكله لكن لما يعض مره واثنين
وثلاثه ويبقى في المكان لمده ثلاث ساعات
وبناء على المشاهدات والدراسات اللي احنا
عملناها قبل كده في وزاره البيئه بياكد ان
هذه السمكه ان كانت طرقت في المياه بنسبه
90% كان هتهاجم انسان ثاني وتسبب وتسبب
وان هذا النوع من القروش لا يترك اصابات
عمليه الوفاه منه بنسبه 100% تقريبا
او هذه القرشه يعني معرفه مؤنث القرش سمكه
القرش
مش اول حادثه تعملها انه سب
هذا الكلام يعني الان
فحضرتك احنا حصل عندنا خلال
22 حادث ايوه لا بقى بس دي دي تحديدا هذه
السمكه
خمس حوادث منها
من هذا النوع واحنا بنقول كل حاجز بيحصل
في مصر بيتم التحقيق في بكل تفاصيله بناء
على بروتوكولات عالميه
اللي لقطتوها الان تبعت السائح
الروسي يعني كانت اكله
انت تقصدي نفس النوع ولا نفس السمكه لا
يستحيل يا فندم مستحيل يحصل ده لا لا هو
نفس النوع اه نفس النوع هاجم قبل كده
خلاص
اربع حالات وفيات وحاله اصابه كانت في سنه
92 الحاله الاصابه الفائح انجليزي لكن هذه
السمكه هي اللي تسببت في حوادث قبل كده
احنا عندنا
من اكثر من سنه وكان برضك تايجر شارك شكرا
على هذه التوضيحات ويعني وضحت لنا كثير من
اللغط اللي صاير على هذا الموضوع والتضارب
في الاقوال بنشكرك كان معنا من الغردقه
عبر الهاتف دكتور محمد سالم رئيس قطاع
حمايه الطبيعه في وزاره البيئه المصريه
شكرا لك
اهلا من جديد كانه قصه نجاتهم لوحدها مو
معجزه كفايه كل شويه بتطلع تفاصيل اضافيه
صادمه بتزيد الدراما في القصه نحن بنتكلم
تحديدا عن نجاه الاطفال الاربعه في
كولومبيا من بعد ما بقيوا 40 يوم في ادغال
الغابات الامازون قصتهم بدات في الاول من
مايو لما نجوا من تحطم طائره صغيره كانوا
فيها مع امهم وقريبهم والطيار وبعدين لقيت
السلطات حطام الطائره وجثث الثلاثه
البالغين وماليقيو الاطفال الاربعه وبدات
عمليات البحث عنهم اللي استمرت اربعين يوم
السلطات خلال هذه الفتره رمت لهم باستخدام
الطائرات خرائط واكل وشرب وماء ودوروا
عليهم بكل الطرق في الغابات الكثيفه حتى
شغلوا مكبرات صوت فيها صوت جدتهم بتطم
منهم وتنادي عليهم الغابات اللي احنا
بنتكلم عنها ترى هي جزء من غابات الامازون
موطن لملاجئ ومخابئ الاصابات غير طبعا
الحيوانات المفترسه والخطيره الاولاد
اعمارهم 13 و9 13 سنه 9 سنوات اربع سنين
وفي رضيع عمره سنه واحده طيب الكلام كله
كان عن الاخت الكبيره لزلي اللي كانت سبب
في انقاذ اخوانها وانتبهت عليهم وبعد ما
لقيوهم نقلوهم او نقلوهم لمستشفى في
العاصمه وقالت السلطات انه راح يبقوا فيها
من اسبوعين لثلاثه نظرا طبعا للحاله
الهزيله اللي لقيوهم فيها طبعا يعني طبيعي
بعد قاعدين اربعين يوم في الضياع في غابه
يعني الكبار حتى ما بينجوا منها ففعليا
معجزه فعلا انهم طلعوا عايشين وفي
المستشفى وكان في انتظارهم كمان عمهم
وجدتهم وقرايبهم احنا من امس مشاهدينا
شفنا الصور من لحظات الانقاذ الاولى وشفنا
فيديوهات نقلهم للمستشفى لكن الجديد نشر
مقاطع للحظات الاولى للعثور عليهم احياء
[موسيقى]
ومن بعد فرحه النجاه دارت اسئله كثيره في
اذهان الناس عن الاولاد والاربعين يوم
وكيف عاشوا وبدات التفاصيل تتوضح شويه
شويه اولها من فرق الانقاذ اللي شافتهم
نزلي البنت الكبيره وجريت عليهم وقالت لهم
جوعانه جوعانه وواحد من الاطفال الاصغر
صرخ امي ماتت وكان مو قادر يمشي من سوء
التغذيه والحال الصعبه فرق الانقاد قالت
كمان انه اول شيء طلبوا الاولاد هو خبز
ورز بحليب واخبروهم الاطفال كمان انهم
كانوا بيسمعوا صوت المروحيات وبيسمعوا
كمان رسائل جدتهم اللي كانوا يحطوها
بمكبرات الصوت من الطيارات وانهم بقيوا
طول الوقت حوالين النهار علشان الماء
ولقيوا مع الاطفال شنطه اخذوها من اغراض
الطياره البنت الكبيره حاطه فيها خيمه من
شفاء مصباح يدوي بطاريات موبايلين طبعا
كلهم بطارياتهم فاضيه وكمان كان معاهم
صندوق مشروبات غازيه كلها ايضا من الطائره
اما بالنسبه للي كانوا بياكلوه فقالوا
الفرق او قالوا الفرق
اكلوا حبوب وفواكه ونباتات بيعرفوها
وبيعرفوا انها مو سامه وبتتاكل كيف عرفوا
هذه المعلومه عرفوها لانهم من السكان
الاصليين وبيعرفوا الغابات والادغال هذه
المعلومات اكدها الزوج الام الراحله وابو
اثنين من الاطفال اللي قال انه لازلي
عندها كل مهارات البقاء على قيد الحياه او
انها تعرف كل شيء وشاطره لكن الجزء الاكثر
صدمه في كلامه هو تفصيله كشفتها
وهو انه الام كانت معاهم اربع ايام وبعدها
ماتت وهي سبب دفعهم للنجاح
في بابا
يعني مثل ما سمعت الام بقيت عايشه مع
اطفالها اربع ايام ووسط بنتها الكبيره
فيهم يعني حقيقه طبعا تفاصيل محزنه جدا
قالوها للاب الجده كمان كشفت تفاصيل ثانيه
كمان بتقطع القلب فلزلي واخوها اللي عمره
تسع سنوات كانوا هم تايهين بيلعبوا لعبه
متعودين عليها ومعروفه عندهم وبيلعبوها من
زمان واسمها لعبه البقاء على قيد الحياه
وفكرتها انه يدخلوا الغابه ويعملوا بيوت
او ملاجئ من الاشجار حواليهم مثل ورق
الشجر وربطات الشعر والسلطات لقيت فعلا
ربطات شعر وملاجئ عاملينها الاطفال وهم في
الغابه وعلى فكره البنت الكبيره اللزلي
متعلمه معظم هذه المهارات من جدتهم اللي
كانت بتساعد امهم في تربيتهم
[موسيقى]
في مقطع فيديو يقال انه من العاصمه
الليبيه طرابلس مال المنصات وشاغل كل
الليبيين
[موسيقى]
مع المقطع المعلومات المتداوله اني شفتوها
هي بنت كانت تتمشى على شاطئ البحر في عز
النهر والطريق مو مقطوع ابدا بالواضح انه
رئيسي والسيارات رايحه وجايه وفجاه وقفت
سياره فيها ملثمين اول شيء نزل واحد لوحده
حوالي ركبها في السياره غصب عنها هي رفضت
وحاولت الهرب منه وبعدين نزل اللي معاه
كمان واحد وحطها فيه او حطوها في السياره
غصب عنها وراحوا وقبل ما يروحوا واحد منهم
نزل من السياره وركب على ما يبدو انه
سياره البنت او سياره تانيه لهم للملثمين
كل هذا بمناسبه تصور وما حد تقرب بعدها
بدات التكهنات والتحليلات
وشيء يقول لا هذا اعتقال مو خطف والفتاه
مخالفه للقانون وغيره وغيرها من القصص لكن
لغايه الان اللحظه اللي احنا فيها ما في
اي معلومات اكيده عن حقيقه الفيديو او
هويه البنت او الملثمين
[موسيقى]
بصادف اليوم 12 يونيو يوم ميلاد فنان
العرب محمد عبده هاشتاج محمد عبده اربعه
وسبعين عام امتلئ بمحبي ابو نوره وهم
بيعيدوه وبيتمنوا له سنه سعيده ومن كم يوم
على فكره ابو نوره كان عنده حفله في جازان
وهناك فريق عملوا منظمين حفل عملوله
مفاجاه واحتفلوا فيه قبل اعيدوا الفعلي
بكم يوم طبعا علشان ما كانت منطقه جازان
كمان في قلبوبك مسقط راس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بسم الله
الله
[تصفيق]
اقدم التحرير
من شركه روتانا على راسها
اخي وحبيبي
الانتاجيه في شركه
روتانا الاستاذ سالم الهندي
طبعا كل عام وابو نوره بالف الف الف خير
والله يديمه علينا نعمه ويديمه صوت كل
مناسباتنا مشاهدينا وصلنا لختام هذه
الحلقه انا اعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله